what made you
um take so much time off i wouldn't say
off but take so much time to work on
a body of work i guess honestly it
wasn't
all working on this project first was
working on me
yeah i was gonna say well i wanted to
get into that because i know you went
through some depression and [ __ ] the
last few years yeah it was like it was
it was kind of like deeper than that you
know i mean like you know
they put titles on on things we go
through you know what i mean but
um yeah i was i was just i was just in a
position where i had been in the game
for so long
i had kind of experienced you know the
ups and the downs of the game and that
you know i mean everything
was to kind of you know feel and
i don't know man just got to a point
where i was like it's all i've ever done
like i got i want to i want to just sit
down and just see what
what my what you know my brain comes up
with you know
and really it was it was like an
investment in myself because i didn't
really work or at least like um
you know work working away like where
like money was coming in all the time
like it was right i had to like
block that uh you know that financial
[ __ ]
uh yeah because you you you you're
always motivated by
the bag as an art you know what i mean
it's like yo when you have so much money
coming in
and and that and you kind of have that
mental expectation in your head like
i'm sure that's hard a hard thing to
turn off yeah
but it was like it was at a point where
it was like cool i could
i could die right now with however much
money in the bank